[Music]
hey you guys
happy sunday night
hopefully you can uh hear us and
everything like that sorry we're so late
but you know how [ __ ] goes
yeah i went out to i wanted to go out
for a ride so i went out
i had a [ __ ] i went down by the bar
yeah you're gonna have to it was [ __ ]
yeah
yeah you were gone all day
and then uh he came back and it was
after five and i said well i guess we'll
push the show to six and then it was
like two minutes to six and i went in
there and he'd fall asleep i was [ __ ]
sleepy so i don't like wake him up i'm
like you know right now like jesus
christ
yeah
i've been like [ __ ] yeah i've been
like trying to prepare for this all day
that it just kept putting getting pushed
back this is a movie we've been wanting
to do for a while because you had
brought this up
a couple weeks ago and i said well you
know shutter just added a [ __ ] ton of
the old like universal classics they've
got like you know dracula frankenstein
bride of frankenstein son of
frankenstein the mummy uh you know so
they had all this and i said i'm pretty
sure they added the black cat as well
because you
had remembered that uh a lot from them
younger
yeah and i had wanted to see it i don't
think that i saw it since i was a kid
and uh yeah the black cat is actually
this came out in 1934
and this was actually the first movie
that uh boris karloff and bella lugosi
did together so they would subsequently
go on to do i think they did eight
altogether uh the two of them but this
was their first one
this movie here is why they came out
with a haze code and ratings well no the
haze code um they actually no no
uh the haze code actually kind of sort
of half-assedly came into the early 30s
but they didn't really enforce it
um as far as this as far as i'm aware
but uh movies like this made them like
enforce it more yeah it's my
understanding that this movie was
[ __ ] helped that ball roll that they
didn't like this movie
yeah and honestly um
legend has it
that the movie
there's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] in it
especially from for 1934 uh i heard that
there was even more [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
that was either just in the script uh or
that they actually filmed and that the
when the producer saw it were like
absolutely not and they had to take it
out it's got murder in it
necrophilia
human sacrifice
satanism
[ __ ] everything it's fun for the
whole family yeah
yeah
um one of the the character that
the character that boris karloff plays
is kind of like
the [ __ ] stereotypical or like the
stereotypical [ __ ] serial killer he's
based on aleister crowley yeah
that's who they based him on alistair
crowley and that dude who made that
[ __ ] murder castle oh yeah hh holmes
h.h holmes it's kind of like that yeah
this is honestly one of i think this
might be
this is easily one of my favorite boris
karloff roles yeah he looks like he's
having a great time in this and honestly
to be honest i like this too because
bella lugosi
i mean he usually played like a monster
you know he played like a vampire or
igor or whatever and in this one
he's not exactly a hero he's not that
great a dude either and actually the
[ __ ] that they cut out of the movie he
was actually way worse
but he is still somewhat sympathetic i
guess only just because boris karloff's
character is like so much more evil
yeah but
uh but yeah so there's that it's about
this dude
he gets out of he gets out of a [ __ ]
prison
and he was a prisoner of war yeah he'd
been in there for like 15 years or
something 15 years he was coming out of
the cool gall
all right and it's it's
it's uh bellagos he's playing him uh his
name is [ __ ] vedis veltegast all
right
and
back in world war one his his army
commander was a guy named uh pelzek his
name was what was it pelsic um that was
his last name yeah yeah harry kallmeyer
yeah shelmar yeah no hyalumar
is there it is because it's spelled
yeah no it's h-j-a-l-o-m-a-r
helmar pelzek
he's uh he was uh fetus's uh commanding
officer during world war one and the guy
was a satanist
and he sells out his own army unit
to the to the uh was it the austrians he
sold it out to who was it they sold it
out there forgot i thought it was the
russians
but i could yeah
and it sells them out for a bunch of
money
and they're all killed on that spot
and uh later on after the war
with the money that he earned from
selling out his own unit he builds this
big [ __ ] castle his own personal
castle
and it's all [ __ ] bauhaus looking
right on the [ __ ] spot where all his
soldiers died
so his soldiers were like a satanic
sacrifice
essentially yeah to consecrate
consecrate the ground for this [ __ ]
this uh
this house that he built
and uh while he's there he has all these
second satanic elites come there to
[ __ ] go to these
human sacrifices yeah for the occasional
human sound yeah
yeah
now um one of the guys that he sold out
was sucking
uh avitas and and
he steals venus's wife
yeah
and it turns out that the [ __ ] not
only that the wife died he has her
embalmed
he's got her [ __ ] hanging up in this
glass castle they imply that he killed
her yeah he implied that he killed her
and uh
it's kind of implied that i guess he's
having sex with the dead body
but it turns out that she was also
pregnant
and venus's daughter he he takes her too
and renames her cat karen which is the
same name as the one the mom yeah and
then mary's the daughter mary's the dog
which was like his stepdaughter i didn't
know was she pregnant at the time or did
because i thought that i thought that um
that vetus
said that you know you took my wife and
daughter so i'm assuming the daughter
was already born
i thought no their daughter was born
yeah yeah so um yes i don't think the
wife was pregnant i think he's using a
daughter as a replacement wife for car
yeah and then uh later on messed up
that's that was yeah yeah
and in this flick
karen carr and two it's a mattel you
know the daughter the car too electric
thinks that her dad is dead but no no
[ __ ] this chick is like no no he's
here he's [ __ ] he he's come to [ __ ]
free you from this
and uh halmar hears this [ __ ] it kills
her
yeah he's got about six or seven bodies
down there in his glass caskets
yeah he keeps them preserved so he can
preserve their beauty forever which like
i said they don't
they don't say outright that he's having
sex with those corpses but
i am pretty sure i mean it's strongly
implied
that there's some necrophilia involved
yeah well evidently uh
back in the 30s they didn't like it
because they thought necrophilia was
[ __ ]
actually stipulated somehow through this
i don't really get that but
it looked like it was just implied to me
but uh no evidently they just straight
up said that no necrophilia is what
they're talking about
but it's very much kind of a serial
killer fantasy this guy's got this
[ __ ]
fantastic high-tech palace
it's real high-tech for the 1930s it's
got sliding doors like somehow star trek
and it's got
interior lighting that's [ __ ] all
hidden up in the ceilings and an
intercom system and
a radio system which all that [ __ ] was
real
high-tech back in the 30s it looked it
looked pretty cool well i kind of like
that because i do kind of feel like the
earlier universal monster movies you
know dracula frankenstein stuff like
that are always kind of set in these
crumbling old gothic castles and i
thought that it was cool that they made
the villains lair
you know for the time like this ultra
modern like art deco ish looking with
all these kind of like silver
uh you know surfaces everything's like
metallic and everything's kind of like
open and minimalist
and in a way that kind of made it
creepier yeah because it wasn't what you
were expecting and he's wearing all
these damn black silk kind of uniforms
double breasted things the [ __ ]
buttons and [ __ ]
and uh
all these satanic brides
walking around in this [ __ ] black
silk with
[ __ ] gauzy dresses with [ __ ]
platinum blonde hair and it's good it's
it's pretty cool pretty cool yeah i mean
i just love the look of this this was uh
the director of this was a guy named
edgar elmer
and this was kind of his first big movie
i don't i don't even really think he got
any more after this
um not so much because this movie wasn't
a hit because it was
but um
it was kind of like
again the the content of it was very
shocking so i think the producers
weren't all that happy about it also
uh i think that he was having an affair
with his boss's wife so that probably
didn't endear him
uh so he didn't really he did direct
some movies after this but this was kind
of like his big
shot at stardom now i think that he was
hungarian if i'm not mistaken so that's
kind of why
uh he kind of like uh said it in that
environment yeah it's like in hungary
and he also uh worked for he worked
under uh fw murnau who did nosferatu and
he also worked under fritz lang who did
metropolis so he was very up in the like
german expressionism uh type thing so
and you can really see that like in the
look of this movie it is like very
expressionist looking i only have one
negative thing about to say about the
movie is that the score doesn't always
fit the the the emotional tone of what's
happening in the movie it's almost kind
of like the score is slightly stock
other than that the movie's [ __ ]
awesome
i mean it's easily one of the best
movies of the 30s and like i said it's
not
it's a lot different than a lot of the
other ones and the thing about it it's
that we kind of laughed when we saw this
but at the very beginning of the credits
it's like uh what do they call it it's
it's not based on edgar allan poe's the
black cat suggested by yes suggestion um
suggested by edgar allan poe like oh
that's a [ __ ] it's suggested by in in
the sense that there is a black cat in
it and you see it yeah well and bella
lugosi's character does have a fear of
black cats which that was from the story
but other than that um that's pretty
much it like nobody gets walled up alive
and you know the guy doesn't kill the
cat with the because doesn't the cat
have like a like a white patch on his
yeah yeah it's like yeah or something
like that or a noose
and like somebody gets walled up and
stuff so it doesn't really have anything
to do with that also i kind of got the
impression
because there's one scene where bella
lugosi
um you know as i said he has like this
horrible fear of cats
and so this black cat like walks by the
doorway all chill and he is just
straight up like picks up a knife and
throws it at the cat now they don't show
the cat dying but they say later on that
he killed the cat
but then you see boris karloff later
with another black cat and he says
something about how black cats don't die
like they're implying that they're
supernatural
uh so i don't know if that was supposed
to be the same cat or if he just had
like a bunch of black cats like around
or i kind of thought
they don't really say this either but i
kind of thought the implication was that
because he was a satanist i thought it
was like his familiar now one scene
that they either shot and took out or
uh never shot because the producer said
you can't put that in there there were
actually more supernatural elements in
the original screenplay
and uh we didn't mention but are sort of
like uh every man every woman that are
kind of like our you know uh our
kind of look into this this story of
depravity are these two uh sort of
clueless honeymooners and they
essentially just run into bella lugosi
on a train like while he's you know
they're on their honeymoon in hungary
he's on the way to the house like to get
revenge because he just got out of
prison and so then there's an accident
so they kind of get swept up in it and
end up in this house now the woman joan
uh bella lugosi his character in this
although like i said he's nominally a
good guy
but in the scenes that were cut out um
he does actually uh i think rape that
woman joan uh there isn't
a thing earlier where he's kind of
because she falls asleep on the train
and he's like starts petting her hair
and stuff
and like her husband's all kind of like
what else
are you touching my wife
but he doesn't get that upset by it it's
like he looks a little pissed he looks a
little pissed but then he's just kind of
like oh she looks so much like whatever
um and i think there was also a scene
too where joan the woman like they
implied that she could shapeshift into
the cat or she became or something like
that so i think that with the cat there
was more of like a supernatural kind of
thing going on that they
took most of it out
but it's not really based on the story
in any meaningful way but you know they
and honestly i think in other countries
it's called something else i think they
just wanted to use uh you know the edgar
allen poe name obviously because they're
like holy crap you know boris karloff
bella lugosi and edgar allan poe you
can't lose
yeah it makes no sense that it has
anything to do with [ __ ]
oh the black cat though it just doesn't
it's not edgar allan poe it's an
original story
yeah and it's it's actually a very
strong original story
it's kind of funny that they tried to
shoehold the shoehorn [ __ ] edgar
allan poe into it well like i said it's
they they're always kind of like on the
lookout for ways to
marketing market it yeah and
you know edgar allan poe being one of
the most iconic horror writers ever
and having these two iconic horror stars
i mean that was going to be a big deal
because like i said they you know they
were both famous on their own but now
this was like the first time they were
teaming up what's weird about this movie
since i you know the second time that i
saw it or saw it recently is that
like an um
vitas shows up and he's got
a henchman or a uh you know like a
[ __ ]
he's a bodyguard and he's old badass he
can walk through [ __ ] damn gunfire
and [ __ ]
to kill the [ __ ] bad guy
and they don't ever [ __ ] make any any
explanation about who he is but for some
reason and i was trying to figure out
what i tried to find what his name was
in the credits
i was under the distinct impression that
he was a mongolian
but i don't know where i got that
because it wasn't in that copy i don't
know if something got caught cut out
from a version that i had seen
or you might be remembering something
from a different movie yeah because that
happens to me sometimes if it was movies
that i saw a long time ago sometimes
i'll mix up he did look a little bit
asian but i was just under the
impression that he was somebody from
mongolia that he had hired but it it
that was a good character though the
[ __ ] bodyguard
i thought that's pretty cool yeah the
thing about it though like
i really really like this was kind of
one of the first movies to go like more
in a psychological horror direction and
again one of the
few from the 1930s that was this
sordid i mean even though by today's
standards it's you know not all that
gory or anything like that but it's
creepy though all of the stuff that's
implied in it yeah is pretty [ __ ] up i
mean you got to think about it yeah
and even the scene at the end where
bella lugosi like essentially flays
boris karloff alive yeah
they just show it in shadow another one
of the scenes that was supposedly cut
out was that afterward they actually had
a shot of boris karloff like crawling on
the ground with some of his skin hanging
off
so as i said i don't know if that was
just as it was written and then they
actually shot it and then they had to
take it out or because what they would
do back then i don't they wouldn't do it
now but back then if they cut something
out of a movie
uh they just destroyed that footage they
didn't keep it anywhere right so if that
stuff actually had been shot
um it wouldn't exist anymore because
they would have just destroyed it as was
commonly done at the time karloff's
great in it he's great man he's so good
in this he's just facial expressions and
everything he's i love like the he's
such a physical actor you know what i
mean like he's
the the one scene where he's introduced
he's laying in bed in the dark with
karen who you find out later is actually
bella lugosi's daughter
um you know so there's that whole [ __ ]
up situation and it's essentially
essentially uh boris karloff's
step-daughter because he had married her
mom and then killed her
but you don't know that until later so
they're laying in the bed and it's dark
and then like he sits up and his back is
like really really straight and all you
see is like his silhouette and his arm
reaches over and he turns the light on
and then he has like this weird like
creepy he just has this creepy
facial expression like his all his
movements in this are just like really
creepy you know what i mean he's just
and he's like so he's kind of like hey i
don't know if i want to say he's hamming
it up a little bit
but
i mean he's clearly having a [ __ ]
ball in this movie the show karloff with
his shirt off and and he's very [ __ ]
lean yeah very lean and and he's not a
young guy but he he looks looking good
he's in good shape which is rare for
this era
um normally these guys were in pretty
bad shape but he was in pretty good
shape for a skinny guy
almost like he'd been
doing a [ __ ]
working out you know yeah because they
do show him with his shirt off like
before the flaying scene
when uh when bella lugosi is like i'm
going to flay you alive
[Laughter]
funny thing about karloff is that you
know that's a stage name he sounds like
he's some something from back in the
hockey motherland somewhere in [ __ ]
russia or something
uh
i didn't know this until [ __ ] fairly
recently but uh boris karloff is like an
indian his dad was from half indian yes
dad was from india and his mother was
from england
um which is
kind of like i think that kind of helped
him in his acting career because you
could put him in an exotic role and
depending on what kind of makeup you put
on him he could be any race he could
play an egyptian from the mummy or he
could play a [ __ ] mexican cowboy or
he could play a british guy or he could
play anything
because he was he's biracial
you wouldn't know by looking at him
though and in some of these uh
some of these roles that they put him in
and that's kind of a testament to
to his strength of an actor he was
everything he could be anything
karloff was the [ __ ]
i mean shutter just added because we
watched it like last week i think they
added um a documentary about boris
karloff called the man behind the
monster and then like i said so they
added a bunch of like oh classic
universal monster movies uh as well
including a lot of boris karloff ones
and so i thought yeah and there was a
lot i knew quite a bit about boris
karloff but there was a lot of stuff in
there that
that i didn't know about him um yeah i
was i thought that i remembered yeah
that he was biracial but they did kind
of like
like you said he had such a distinctive
look even by the time this movie came
out you know 1934 he was such a big star
that on the poster if you notice they
don't even put his first name they just
put karloff yeah and bella lugosi so he
was just he had become like a one named
actor
just on the strength of frankenstein
yeah
um
because
he looked cool i mean you look cool his
face and [ __ ] honestly i love bella
lugosi too i love like all of those old
universal monsters but boris karloff
there was just something like really
i don't know there's just something like
really magnetic about him he's like so
weird looking but like in a really kind
of hot way yeah you know what i mean and
he had that great voice and he had that
weird lisp yeah i mean he just had
people were jealous of him evidently
though i mean
[ __ ] you know uh
again
some hollywood stars said that he was he
was dumb he was like
i don't know if he was dumb i didn't see
him but you know what dumb and [ __ ]
and
uh
bella bella lugosi just straight up
called him a [ __ ]
well i don't know if that's
true or if that was like tell us
if they just played that up like for the
ed wood movie like maybe
because like i said they actually the
two of them were in a lot of movies
together and i don't know if there was
some kind of like if their relationship
soured later on yeah but well that's
weird because i remember you telling me
i had never heard that that people said
that boris karloff was was dumb yeah and
uh when
and when we were watching that
documentary they actually had you know
interviews with people that had known
him and like family members and they had
a lot of um you know footage of like
interviews he had done and he doesn't he
doesn't sound dumb he sounds like very
intelligent and very articulate who
wasn't saying it was so it was some
hater probably it was it was a female
[ __ ] it was a female um actress from
hollywood maybe he broke up with her
since she was mad so
you know for i can't remember who it was
she just said that you know behind all
that hype is that basically you're just
doing what the dude was dumb
but i don't know if it's true or not
it's just funny how they're all [ __ ]
they're all good that's what i'm saying
i kind of feel like because i he never
struck me as because believe me i've
heard some interviews with actors that
kind of sounded like idiots karloff does
not sound like that he sounds very
articulate and very educated um in every
thing that i've ever heard him talk
about
so well a lot of it is course you know
stage presence and professionalism
he was a hired hand for most of his life
until he you know until he finally got a
solid job acting you know yeah he was
just a
guy that you'd [ __ ] hire to [ __ ]
fix your cupboards
but so but so was harrison ford yeah
harrison ford would fix your [ __ ]
cupboards well yeah that's that's it
that's it that sounds like
some harrison ford will fix your
cupboards oh yeah yeah
oh my god you gotta do something between
jobs i know
juan romero says wearing the
frankenstein getup whipped him into
shape yeah he uh actually had back
problems for his entire life uh from
that
from all the stuff they made him wear
well because uh and i did slash a fred
brought up the movie gods and monsters
uh which is a great movie i actually
want to see that again i saw it several
years ago uh but it's about
james whale who the guy who directed uh
frankenstein and bride of frankenstein
and uh it's really really good and uh
juan romero says carlos is an awesome
vampire and black sabbath yeah that's
right and uh what is that called the
deverculak or whatever that is yeah he's
like the best part of that
um
yeah god's monster is a good movie and
carlos and lugosi were also in the raven
we should probably do that one because i
remember really liking that movie the
raven is kind of more
comedic though also really nothing much
to do with the edgar allan poe story but
you know what are you gonna do
um
it was a name that sold like i said
edgar allan poe so they're gonna have
all this stuff in there it's weird
because bella lugosi
was in another movie called the black
cat which came out in 1941 that i think
had basil rathbone in it
and i think that that one was also not
based on the incredible story i don't
know if it was marketed as
so you know people piss and moan
nowadays about movies and it's just like
oh my god they just they made another
one but it was like [ __ ] it wasn't
even 10 years later they made another
black hat that i think was like
completely different
than this one and didn't have anything
to do maybe having even less to do at
least this black cat had a black cat in
it and it did have a guy in the story
who was terrified of black cats which
that's from the story
but that's about it but that's okay
that's okay it's still a great movie it
is it's and honestly if you haven't seen
it
it's kind of one of those ones yeah you
need to see like all the classic
universal monster stuff from the 30s
like you know it's frankenstein and
bride of frankenstein and dracula and
stuff
but i kind of feel like this is one that
people don't talk about as much
but
this one absolutely is worth because
it's a lot different than those ones a
lot different like more realistic the
look of it is different and yeah and i
think like i said they did have in the
original cut they did have some kind of
more supernatural elements in the sense
of you know like the cats being familiar
or them being shape shifters and stuff
but they cut out a lot of that stuff to
make it more of like a human monster
type of thing or like more of a
psychological horror and that hadn't
really been done all that much so this
was kind of one that was a lot different
than the other stuff that was around at
the time
and um as i said it did do very well but
because of its subject matter
um
as i said i think the haze code had been
kind of floating around prior to this
but wasn't really all that enforced but
then this came out and that might have
like pushed the
them into being like okay well now we
really need to crack down because
necrophilia and flying alive and
genocide and rape and
neck and you know having like this
having boris carl avery yeah like having
boris karloff like marry a woman and
then kill her and then marry the
daughter and it's just like they kill
that one and then kill her and then it's
like it's very very [ __ ] up even
though they don't show it like in front
of your face but just the implication of
it i mean can you imagine like going to
see this in the 30s that must have been
like that must have blown their [ __ ]
minds man and like one one of the best
parts about it is you got [ __ ]
karloff dressed up in this [ __ ]
really cool looking [ __ ]
black satin outfits with all these
buttons in here he looks so great looks
like his hair yeah the hair with like
the [ __ ] it's all pointed yeah oh
it's great and he's in this high-tech
[ __ ] bauhaus looking [ __ ] castle
and
[ __ ] vetus you know [ __ ] played by
like
[ __ ]
uh like bella lugosi is going you know
you murdered and sold off your whole
army unit to build this castle and just
calls him all kinds of [ __ ] you raped my
wife and you still and he just never
denies it he just sits there with a smug
smile on his face going yeah yeah [ __ ]
i did all that yeah i guess i did
i mean people say anything he didn't
even
deny he's just sucking smiling do i feel
bad you know yeah he's just really good
and it goes on through the whole movie
all these accusations about all this
[ __ ] horrible [ __ ] that he's doing
and he's just going like
yeah
yeah yep yeah that's me
yeah deal with it that was how he's
building his satanic empire
yeah just i love his facial expressions
yes it's just funny because i mean you
know much later i mean the first
exposure i had to boris karloff when i
was a little kid was obviously how the
grinch stole christmas
and you know because of his voice and
everything but they also modeled the
animated grinch after his face a little
bit yeah which so so now every time
particularly in this movie whenever he
does that evil grin type of thing i'm
always kind of thinking yeah
i have to keep christmas from coming but
how i always kind of like think of that
because he has that [ __ ] evil ass
like look to him and they just i really
love the like the theatricality of the
makeup that they did on him like i said
he's very
it's very extreme looking he's got all
the aleister crowley robes like all the
black silk and everything and uh
it is weird because it's also kind of
paramilitary yeah he has that going on
as well but like his hair
is just kind of like it's almost kind of
like i want to say it's like a like a
low-key pompadour a little bit but it's
kind of like it's very very sharp it's
got like a widow's peak like a widow's
peak but it's like it's it's like a
[ __ ] hardcore widow's piece it goes
like all the way but it's like very very
sharp and very black and he tells people
to do [ __ ] and just like
go and he [ __ ] points and [ __ ] with
his hands like this you know that's what
i mean it's just i love like every
movement in this
yeah
and every movement in this is just so
about the movie is that when vitas shows
up for some strange reason
his
bodyguard becomes
[ __ ] hair chalmers [ __ ] uh servant
i don't uh i
it has something to do with the guy just
rank
that yeah
i wasn't entirely sure like if you come
to somebody's house your servants become
their servants i don't really understand
how that happens then must be some kind
of honky rules back in the hockey rolls
well maybe because boris karloff's
character was a was of higher military
rank than bella lugosi yes sir so
something like that i mean that's maybe
what we thought it was but you had to
play into that game until the very end
and when the assassination was i liked
too that like bella lugosi i mean you
know the honeymooners kind of get swept
up in it by accident because like i said
they have there's a car accident joan is
wounded so they end up all having to go
to the house whereas bella lugosi was
just going there by himself
and then joan is kind of like uh you
know he's like oh i had to kill my
daughter so now i'm gonna uh or my
daughter wife and now i'm gonna use you
for the human sacrifice that the whole
satanic shindig i'm having so there was
that whole situation going on too
but i like that bella lugosi
was going there to get revenge she
didn't really make any secret about that
but i liked that there was this kind of
like weird
mutual respect between the two guys like
it's almost kind of like boris carlos
like yeah you came here to like [ __ ] me
up and it's like i probably have it
coming but it was it was like this weird
little cat and mouse type of thing and
bella lugosi is just kind of like well
i'm gonna hold off to because i wanna
like i want it to happen at the right
time he wanted to like go about it the
right way and all this other stuff so it
wasn't just like he showed up and was
just like i'm gonna kill you
[ __ ] it was kind of like this
like psychological
back and forth between the two of them
like he was kind of waiting for the
right time and boris karloff was kind of
kind of trying to get him on his side a
little bit he's like oh you need to come
to my satanic party tonight you'll enjoy
it and all this other stuff and it
almost seemed like bella lugosi was kind
of
into it a little bit because remember
well he took him down to the basement
and showed him all the he's like hey
check out my collection collection
here's your wife's wife and yeah and
bella was just like sad about it he
didn't go what the [ __ ] is that you know
what i mean which a normal person would
you would go to there would be like like
that she died i wanted to keep her
beauty forever you know he's like is
that weird am i coming across as weird
well it's like it is a little bit weird
but it's not that weird maybe i don't
know so that's what i mean
about bella lugosi's character being
a nominally better guy but
not he's still not a good guy well they
were playing remember they were playing
jet chess yeah looking for the for the
for joan for the woman
joan and
bella says if i win then she can leave
but if you try to save him but playing
the game is was enough to be like that's
kind of strange why not just go the
authorities but evidently they couldn't
there was some kind of an honor bound
stuff and yeah it was very much that and
uh venus was there for vengeance he was
going to commit a murder
he was going to kill this dude from
outside outside the confines of civilian
law this was some personal [ __ ]
so he couldn't tell anybody what he was
doing or what was going on because that
would deny him his personal vengeance i
believe is part partly what it was yeah
uh so he was there on on a he was there
basically on an illegal mission so he
couldn't tell anybody what was going on
which yeah that makes sense you're like
well i came here to like murder although
kill you right yeah i mean i guess you'd
have plausible than eyeball i was just
coming to visit my old friend and i
don't know what happened how he got shot
and it's you know it was that kind of
thing well he kind of tells him on the
train that he's coming to [ __ ] get
vengeance on a dude
did he yeah did he tell him i kind of
feel like he did i don't know if he said
it that bluntly but he did kind of say
that yeah there's this [ __ ] and i'm on
the way yeah i'm going to kill this dude
and they're all kind of like
they're just like i said they're like
these clueless american
yeah inclusive american couple is
basically the uh the stand-in for you
the audience
everything's being explained to you
simple americans
who don't know
anything about the evil of europeans
yeah you go [ __ ] that's really you're
being thrust into this like all of this
stuff and with genocide and satanism and
stuff and you don't understand it and
they're just kind of like
yeah only europeans would know about
this so you got it and they're just kind
of like oh [ __ ] okay i'm in the middle
and then at the end there's
the american couple was like oh who
would have believed it nobody would have
believed this
that's what like after all that they
went through and all the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that happened because they saw that
stuff like they saw the guy get flayed
they saw all the dead women in the
basement yeah and then they're like on
the train afterwards like well just
continuing the honeymoon wasn't that
crazy yeah yeah exactly exactly exactly
who would believe it nobody play that
[ __ ] nobody that happened that's
ridiculous
that was
ridiculous no one would believe the
story they were just said they weren't
traumatized enough
i thought that was really really funny
um but you know some people have read
that
as almost uh a kind of
not an indictment necessarily but they
were kind of making a sly joke about the
americans uh showing up like kind of at
the end of world war one you know what i
mean being like hey here we are like
just kind of like you know flopping
around and not really knowing what was
going on but you know it's some people
have read it like that
um
juan romero says love that stop-motion
karloff in mad monster party man i need
to re-watch that because i remember
[ __ ] loving that as a kid and i was
just thinking about it the other day and
i was like [ __ ] man i need to rewatch
that
um
slasher friend says the plot of the
movie is very similar to the old dark
house yes it is uh the old dark house i
think is also on shutter or it was i
don't know if it's still on there i saw
it a long time ago because like i said i
really like all these old
black and white movies and i really like
old silent movies so i've seen a lot of
them but uh it's been a while since and
i honestly kind of wanted to re-watch
the old dark house at some point so i'll
see if shutter still has it
but uh
so i guess are we are we done yeah yeah
that's good enough yeah well um
now tomorrow we're going in a completely
different direction yeah and we're gonna
talk about and we'll probably do it at
three o'clock tomorrow like normal
because actually tomorrow night we have
to go out we have to get a memento
um
tomorrow we're going to talk about a
burt reynolds 70s movie yeah
we just saw it randomly when we were
going through amazon prime like free to
me movies
and tom's like let's watch this one
white light white lightning and there's
a second movie called gator i had seen
gator yeah um and i didn't realize until
after they said what burt reynolds
character's name was in this one i said
wait is this that to do with that one
because i've seen that yes it is
you can see white lightning for free on
on
amazon right now amazon prime i
recommend it it's the most accurate
movie depicting the south and southern
culture of the 70s i know i was there i
was a little baby
but in 73 but by the time [ __ ] the
late 80s had rolled around it was still
kind of like that a lot of still
the south was still kind of like that
it's taken place in arkansas which
wasn't a big difference between arkansas
and mississippi you know just regional
differences but it's a good movie it's
it's uh i had a good time with it uh had
some ned babies in there playing a
villain please good feeling but uh yeah
reynolds we'll save it for bart reynolds
is like the southern james bond all
right
a different story uh but it's
it was made by a company that did movies
in the south
for the south by the south
they didn't care if it sold outside the
southern part of america because
once they went to theaters
um turned out like uh memphis tennessee
the ticket sales are there there was a
loan to cover the cost of the movie so
they just made
some movies in the south in the 70s in
the in the early 80s and they they did
well
i think uh
i think smoking the band it was also the
same company wasn't it i think it was
well uh hal needham for sure worked on
both of both movies i'm not sure what
the production company was so but it was
a good production company go check out
white lightning and we'll talk about it
later yeah we're going to talk about
that tomorrow like i said it's
completely different from this one and
then i don't know we watched another
movie last night
um that was from the 70s but i don't
know if we necessarily want to cover it
or not because it was terrible which one
the doug mcclure one uh
don't worry about that one yeah it was
that was really not worth watching white
lightning was kind of like the mad max
of the south it has a lot of the
reminded me of a lot of [ __ ] mad max
1
in a certain way similar i could see how
mad max may have [ __ ]
ripped off
some of the stuff from white lightning
well like i said there was kind of a
whole sub sub genre of these types of
movies going on back in the second car
with like southern stuff and like car
chases and frontier type badassery
yeah but um when we come to [ __ ]
southern culture and [ __ ] badass [ __ ]
from back in the day
so far
this is one of the best movies of the
south that i've seen
cheryl says burt reynolds day yeah bart
reynolds is the [ __ ]
and he's pretty young in this one i
didn't realize that burt reynolds was as
handsome as he was when when bert was
always looked pretty good in the movies
i saw but in 73 he was uh very handsome
i could see why he was so popular
very handsome yeah he's very uh he's
very charismatic yeah juan ramirez says
black cat white lightning i know i
thought of that too and we totally did
not even do that on purpose we just
watch random [ __ ] you guys
a lot of times
yeah a lot of times we don't uh plan it
sometimes we do but not usually uh what
we'll usually do is we'll go through
like i said i have hulu we have shutter
and we'll kind of like go through amazon
prime the free ones and just whatever
we're in the mood for watching
we'll watch that so it could be
literally anything that comes up that we
just feel like we're in the mood for
so in the white lights white lightning
series there's two of them there's white
lightning and then there's gator i
haven't seen we haven't seen gator yet
but i saw it a long time but gator's
supposed to be better than white light
yeah we'll see
got to do excalibur someday we did do it
a long time ago it was a long time ago
though
maybe we'll revisit it sometimes yeah
because that was honestly that was maybe
in
in the first year that we were doing the
show one of my favorite movies i think
that we did that one yeah yeah and uh
that same director did zardoz also yeah
john gorman yeah great movie yeah uh
okay so we'll be back tomorrow talking
about burp reynolds from universal
classics to burt reynolds uh moonshining
so yeah that's just how we roll on this
[ __ ] show
so uh yeah so have a good rest of your
weekend i know there's not much of it
left at this point uh and we will see
you guys again tomorrow afternoon bye